[Applause]
i did um i met trey songz i was doing
the last ever spring break for mtv it
was in
the video i didn't notice his dick being
that big in the trunks in the trunks and
i feel like a dick that big i would have
definitely seen
it's like the mark's ass of dicks
[Laughter]
there's a moment in the next brilliant
idiots episode which came out yesterday
where mark walks past the camera and
charlemagne who is on zoom
[Music]
stops the podcast because all he saw was
mark's hair and a bun and then an ass
and goes
hi schultz
i see what you got working over there
okay the miami studios
bro literally stops the podcast as a
comment on mark's ass and then mark
walks back in full beard and then
charlotte has to realize yeah hey yo hey
yo gay rumors might be true
it's real out there but you you gotta
you got to stop a positive okay just
have an affinity for large asses that
was one of the first things i noticed
about mark is that he had a fatty yeah i
just noticed he got that soccer ass yeah
i got the thickems bro yeah you got that
comes in
you got high set yeah i got high ass
that's the thing bro i got a little ass
on me but i have yeah you know i do have
me yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
yo but for real dude ow don't tell my
ass there is something i've noticed
about my ass i don't know if i've shared
this about you guys but i have a high
set [ __ ]
yeah how would we notice that i have a
high set [ __ ] whenever i [ __ ] i
always hit the back of the toilet wall
bank shot every single time old school
tim duncan
[Applause]
[Music]
a fatty i got a fatter ass in ul
oh my ass is way fatter i twerk it out
right now you know it's not even close
i bet you twenty thousand dollars my ass
fatter than you how do we prove it i'll
take my ass out right now
i'll take my whole ass out right now
and i'll put it right next to your ass
and then we see who got more volume but
how how he judging though but if he
shaves his ass seventy-five percent of
it is gone that's also true but we're
including hair psychonautically we're
not including hairs on no we are not a
quest love all right fine
fine fair enough even without the hair i
definitely got fatter ass in you 100 100
you don't i'm telling you i know this
for a fact i've seen your ass i've seen
you walk around you don't you don't have
a great ass you don't yeah
your ass looks like you're holding in a
[ __ ]
that's what your ass looks like
literally probably have a fatter than
you there's no
we'll figure out a way to judge this one
dove can judge it bro
right now you've got a nicer chest yeah
okay
i have way better lower half
you got nicer upper i got way better
lower it's not even close
the legs
the legs it's daddy long legs over here
this
you could enter special olympics right
now
right now we put him in a wheelchair as
a little person
[Laughter]
i was in a wheelchair and someone just
noticed him like go like
someone nobody would question nobody
would question that go out don't don't
ever put your ass up against mine bro
yeah yeah right yo literally
right here in front of the camera stand
yo you judge for us bro i can't look at
andrew's balls like this oh [ __ ] that
[ __ ] is making me uncomfortable
wow okay so hey i'll andrew
it's only going to help you to pull down
your pants
al refuses to take out his ass
yeah
oh my god
[Laughter]
i'll take out your shirt i'm trying to
help you here
wait
wait hold on he's trying to make the
other way
andrew is in pole position right now
he's trying to make the underwear
pull up his hands
yo who winning that's
that's andrew by a mile oh my god i'm
sorry ow wait al show us your friends
show us your front because you got that
you got it no
no i mean yeah
dubs i try to make
[Laughter]
i got a feeling about mark mark i think
if he takes the pants off ass falls
apart
he's a shower not a grower exactly
that's it if i take this [ __ ] off hold
on
yo al you're not even close
your boy got hang time
bro your ass looked like dried ham
you look like the spanish ham bro
look at this [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
non-existent
yo andrew man who got you bro i'm
packing up
how about to start hitting these squats
bro
yeah he's been doing the squats he's not
doing right i haven't you got to do the
squats with your legs i haven't hit this
you're doing the squats with bro you
really didn't have the right underwear
for today right underwear
[ __ ] tighty whiteys hey you want to
run it
white underwear black is slimming you
put the white on
his back no no no you have you might
have only one ass cheek bro you might
have just a so you don't have anything
your [ __ ] is a dorsal fin how do you
shoot
yeah that's what you look like you got
cone heads yeah ass cheeks looks like
two coneheads bro that's what it is
honestly
neither do i no the movie dan aykroyd i
don't know no no no no
that she came to a point it's stuck out
very far yeah what is that no but it
doesn't matter point is you got no s and
we need to have a conversation about
that all right guys we're gonna take a
break from this exclusive patreon clip
because i gotta make sure that you're
handling your federal student loans the
right way and you know who's going to
help you out it's earnest federal
student loans have been on hold but come
january 31st when the cares act payment
hold expires you'll be back to paying
your federal student loans today's
sponsor earnest can help you out but
make sure you review the cares act
disclosures carefully before you're
refinancing your loan ernest is the
number one student loan financer in the
country they earn the top spot by
helping thousands of people get better
rates lower their monthly payments or by
helping their customers combine multiple
loans into a simple monthly payment and
earnest doesn't charge any fees ever not
even late fees so take two minutes yes
it's only two minutes and see what your
new rate could be and don't worry
there's no credit impact if you have
questions ernest has an in-house team
ready to help and you can always talk to
a real live human being when you pay
less interest you can put that money
towards your goals so right now ernest
is offering our listeners a 100 cash
bonus refinance your student debt at
earnest.com flagrant okay remember this
is not available in all states once
again if you
if you go you can get right now a 100
cash bonus when you visit earnest.com
flagrant to refinance your student loan
visit earnest.com flagrant for more
details not available in all states
terms and conditions supply earn a
student loan refinancing made by earnest
operations llc and mls number one two
zero four nine one seven california
financing law license number six zero
five four seven eight eight five thirty
five mission street san francisco
california 94105 visit earnest.com
licenses for a full list of licenses now
let's get back to this exclusive patreon
clip
yeah this is an intervention we're going
to have an intervention bro
you can't have a black owned business
and claim puerto rica and you got no
assets that's crazy actually that's and
wheezy don't have it ain't got no s whoa
whoa
i'm telling you this is a problem bro
yeah if i see you i wouldn't want you to
run my studio bro if you had an ass like
that bro because you're half-assed
if i see you half-assed did you see that
joke
mark out here with the [ __ ] fortune
cookie bar all right
i'm a laffy taffy today bro i got it
i'm gonna have all the dad jokes yo can
we see yo can we see who got uh more hip
fat you or akash oh that's me for sure
that's me for sure
i got that hourglass victor bro oh dove
and akash go hip fat friends oh yeah
it's a panera bread let's go hey come on
let's do it nah bruh my [ __ ] i won doug
you got some hang right here oh i got it
hang on can we see it i got hang bro
look at that oh
both of you stand up next to each other
and turn your back to the camera and
then just pull up your shirts and we
want to see
i'm the single one here nope come on bro
you out here smashing man i just showed
my no ass
that is true we got the most vulnerable
but you thought if adam had no ass from
the jumper he knew he don't have no ass
bro i just i know i don't have ass i
just thought it was bigger than his
honestly i feel disrespected we've known
each other for multiple years you
haven't noticed that i'm packing fat
hey hey
you're disrespected by
this is a typical aldo remember when i
broke the fence and literally the whole
pole is
noticed and he walks up and goes oh i'll
fix it and thinks that he can go and
bend the pole back i didn't put it you
didn't bend it i bent it he didn't come
closer he thinks that he could do
everything and i bent it oh you're dead
he thinks he can be white people than
anything that's what it is
oh that's what it is
[Music]
wow
who do you think could win and uh snap a
dick off with your butt cheeks challenge
between you
bro
[Laughter]
i got that [ __ ] bro yeah but alex is
sharp
you got like bumpers and bowling uh-uh
that's what you look like my ass is a
cigar cutter you kidding me
you slide that [ __ ] in there click flip
it
let's take this podcast to the next
level yeah
not for real i got a fake hunted
for whoever is trying to cut this cigar
dog
i got a fake
button your pants dog it's just been um
your [ __ ] is still down oh man it's just
so much more comfy like
you hit 30 70 skinny jeans i ain't with
it duh stop googling lipo
and akash are going to have a
competition
okay and it's who got more hip fat okay
what do we call hip fat what's another
name don't like handles i love him
yeah yeah whoa yeah i got that hourglass
bruh dude i feel like scarlett johansson
out this [ __ ] yeah you might have more
than an hour
[Music]
is diwali on the lunar calendar yeah all
indian holidays all hindu holidays are
around the lunar calendar aren't you
guys smart
why are you going off the moon sudden
the sun is right there yeah i've been
doing bad mass another lunar calendar
[ __ ] is always different days what it
don't line up diwali is not gonna be the
same day on this calendar next time i
hate that
i hate that i hate that move around [ __ ]
bro
yo it's fun though you don't know when
it's coming i don't like it it's hard to
plan
you're a big planner big
y'all if y'all figured out what you're
gonna do with your girl for valentine's
day
i didn't know valentine's coming up
until you brought it up yesterday son
got it i don't know we're working on it
right now
oh yeah by way i mean dev and i are
working you guys want to hire me to
produce your valentine's day because i'm
honestly you could do that do you want
to take my girl on valentine's day
though because this might be easier bro
holy [ __ ] that's a brilliant idea that's
what i'm saying i have to pay right and
i have to pay
you just come at the end of the night
you could you could offer a professional
service yeah that's the best date
you hire a guy to take your girl out
he's like a dog walker oh
yeah
we can't call our wives that that's
crazy i love my dog say what i love my
dog mark you're a crazy
boy wow
jesus is not i ain't getting cut out
either no we're keeping that one in
cut it out
that's the thing white people let us let
dogs kiss our mouths so i'm fine with
that that's the one thing he's trying
he's trying to get it back but he can't
get it back you gotta you gotta take
that one bro take one you gotta
she's literally gonna listen to this
podcast friday and then you got one full
day
to get her back on her good side when do
you think valentine's is yeah yeah ain't
it this weekend
you're getting lunar calendar bruh you
won't be knowing no way is valentine's
on lunar yeah it is
what
[Music]
is valentine's on lunar why is that [ __ ]
be moving around
it's not
i don't think it is oh it just moves
around the day not the date it's the
same date that's how solar calendars
work dog oh [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] solar
calendar heaven has
a dummy [ __ ] i'm a dumbass for that one
i just know my girl's birthday is the
same day is it
oh that's so lit it is lit but it's not
why because i gotta spend hella extra to
do things because yeah but it's the
efficiency of it yeah yeah but it's not
exactly we can knock it out
do you have to do two dates no but i
gotta go for it i gotta go for it extra
extra extra do you think one day is she
big on her birthday i gotta go i'm gonna
have to do both days do you have to do
both or could you do like 1.75 you know
what i mean you don't have to go double
i could do 1.75 but that's the thing you
can slide on 1.75 i think yeah what we
usually would do is like we'd go away or
something like that but we just went
away yeah here's the we're away yeah so
we've got to find something that's here
yeah also corona and all that kind of
[ __ ] but it is nice in that regard
because you do one kid
we have to take this
oh you know we got to be careful with
[ __ ] we got to take this seriously
it's a global pandemic
it's a global pandemic it's highly
contagious mutated strains there's
mutated strains it's very difficult to
do bro okay we have to take this very
seriously we do we do okay no i mean
it's just hard to travel these
[ __ ] don't want to let you in
their goddamn countries same bart's
closed
damn i think it is wild that america not
let in anywhere i should feel it feels
away
yo but you know how arrogant we are yeah
when we find out that news we're like
what
yeah we can't go yeah why would you want
us yeah it is crazy i was a [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you can't come here yo we like the
knicks we're like wait you don't wanna
wait you don't wanna yeah and then we're
not good enough for you yeah yeah yeah
yeah i heard bro that hurt when you said
that
i think um i think we might have to keep
that same energy with countries that
don't let us in yeah like you know
[ __ ] even after it's done canada
can't come back here no more though done
done yeah
no i think it's strong i think about the
hood hold the line come on i understand
the hose alex is white [ __ ] to speak
patois
him when he found out there were white
girls that could wind
oh yeah yeah
[Music]
that's he said that exact sentence
multiple times i just didn't know there
were white women that could find like
he's got nice people man just nice
people yeah it's a good culture yeah
it's a good culture strong people nice
people kind people i agree they should
be banned for 10 years yes
just put a little bit of of fear what up
people you just watch a clip from our
weekly patreon episode you can support
the flagrancy you can support this
unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join you should because it's a top 10
patreon in the [ __ ] world that's
right for a good reason go check out why
at patreon.com flagrant2
all right peace
[Applause]
you